all right so because of our vacation
last week it's been almost two full
weeks since we did our last coveted
update cases
hospitalizations deaths vaccinations
and i i think while there's still
caution
i would characterize today's report is
good news compared to what we were
seeing two weeks ago it did look for a
little bit there a couple of weeks ago
like we might be seeing a pretty bad
turnaround with cases
first leveling off and even climbing
slightly for about seven to ten days and
there were
concerns about are we heading towards a
fourth wave or a fourth spike
that uptick in cases has now reversed
in some states they're still spiking and
we'll talk about why
but the cases are coming back down
deaths continue down
vaccinations have dramatically
accelerated and i
believe after looking at the data
talking to a few doctors yesterday and
today
and just looking at what dr fauci said
recently as well
i believe we are on the path to a very
good situation by memorial day which is
may 31st the last day of may
uh right around eight weeks from today
so let's dig right into the data
cases you might recall peaked at 256 000
a day back in mid-january
and started to decline bottoming out in
the middle of march around
55 000 per day but by the time our break
started
the cases had actually trickled back up
to about 68 000 a day
up from 55k to 68k
and that's when the fourth wave
discussion started
uh the cause of that uptick appears to
be a combination of
unvaccinated people going wild if you
look at for example who's getting the
virus
lately it is more and more younger
people getting the virus not yet
vaccinated but acting as if
we've reached herd immunity combined
with a more contagious
british variant which is essentially
dominant in some places michigan is one
place where we've seen a lot of that
the northeast is another place it
appears as though
we may not be on the way up because
again
cases are starting to decline from that
68k
pop down to about 64. now that's a small
change it's not totally obvious that
we're on the way back down but at least
we're not continuing to see an increase
and if vaccination continues to
accelerate we should see
substantial case declines over the next
eight weeks
and i'll tell you why a little bit later
in terms of deaths
the strategy of vaccinating the most
likely to die
if they get the virus after doing health
care workers of course
is working even as cases leveled out and
we said well
you know deaths are on a three-week
delay from cases we may see deaths level
out
they didn't deaths have continued down
the entire time
you might remember they peaked at nearly
3 500
per day more than a 911 a day in january
they went below 3 000 a day in the first
week of february
below 2 000 a day around february 20th
below 1 000
a day uh in that fourth week of march
and now
down to just a hair over 800 deaths a
day
still horrifying still a tragic number
but one that is now down about 77
from its peak in late january this
should continue because cases aside
even against the variants the vaccines
are nearly 100
effective at preventing death
vaccination
over the weekend the u.s had consecutive
days
with 4 million vaccines per day we are
now
averaging just over 3 million doses
per day this means that every day
roughly one percent of the u.s
population is getting a shot
now it's not one percent is being fully
vaccinated each day a lot of those are
two dose regimens
so still one percent of the us
population is now getting
a shot every day the reason we know this
will pay off
in about six to eight weeks is we look
at israeli data
israel has now vaccinated more than 55
percent
of its population they are basically
wide open
passover was almost a completely normal
passover with gatherings and everything
and cases and hospitalizations
serious coveted deaths are all down
down down dramatically we have the chart
up on the screen for our video audience
it looks very very good now then we get
to
but but but david what about those
variants yeah the variants
are concerning eight nine ten months
from now
maybe even six to eight we may be
seeing new booster vaccines dialed in
for these variants
the current vaccines work pretty well
against the variants they work less well
but they work pretty well
and they are almost as effective at
preventing serious covet and death in
almost every case here's a graphic
from dr eric topple who we've
interviewed on the program i highly
recommend following him on twitter about
the variants against the uk variant
a very modest reduction in vaccine
efficacy
against the south african variant a
little more reduction
we don't yet have real world data about
the brazilian variant
but that's the least prevalent variant
in the u.s and
in vitro studies serum studies show
that the vaccines still work against the
brazilian variant but we do have to keep
vaccinating
faster it's a race what will we do what
will happen
faster these variants becoming
predominant or
vaccination israel is predominantly the
british variant
and they are as i showed you completely
dominating this joe biden today expected
to announce
another major advance in full
vaccination eligibility
remember joe biden about a month ago
said may 1st
i want every state making everybody
eligible
today and it may happen before you
listen to today's show
joe biden expected to announce that he's
moving that up by a couple of weeks
april 19th now there will be full
vaccine eligibility all good news
going in the right direction let's keep
going
one of the reasons i've been telling you
that it's unclear
that the trump riots will have much of
an impact on american politics going
forward
is that many americans either won't
remember what happened on january 6th
or will remember it but fall for lies
about what it was that took place and
believe something that's a complete
fantasy
we now have evidence that this is
happening there is a new
reuters ipsos poll released yesterday
which found
look at this half of republicans
believe that the trump riots were
left-wing activists merely trying to
make trump look
bad or largely non-violent protests
neither of those assertions is true
three in ten republicans believe that
trump is partially responsible for the
riots
seven and ten do not sixty percent of
republicans
believe that donald trump's uh believe
trump's lies
that the 2020 election was stolen 60
percent
60 percent of republicans believe that
donald trump
should run in 2024 and
80 percent of republicans have favorable
opinions of
trump many important things to note
number one i said yesterday it would be
irresponsible for a show about american
politics to ignore donald trump right
now
partially because he still is uh the
face of the republican party
overall this poll again comes confirms
that
sixty percent want him running in in
three two four years
three to four years eighty percent still
view him favorably
sixty percent believe his lies that he
actually was the rightful winner of
twenty twenty so
again that is born out number two
this doesn't suggest that trump and
republicans are going to be held
accountable
in 2022. maybe in 2022
they will be held accountable for other
things things that haven't yet happened
things that will be more
fresh and recent in the minds of
republican voters but there is
no evidence whatsoever that the trump
riots
and the way that republicans defended it
are going to have any serious impact on
2022
but the voters either either don't
believe it um or they've forgotten
or whatever um as i mentioned
very much the party of trump they also
claim to be the party of personal
responsibility
but they take no responsibility and
assign no responsibility or blame to
their own elected officials ever
ever i was kind of stepping back as i
was reading these poll numbers
and considering the absurdity of the
situation remember that donald trump
lost the popular vote by millions
in 2016. he accomplished essentially
zero of his campaign promises
he was going to pay off the debt he
didn't do it he was going to build a
wall across the u.s mexico border he
didn't do it he was going to replace
obamacare with something beautiful he
didn't do it
he was going to fix trade he didn't do
it i could give you the whole list
never had an approval rating over 50 the
only president in the polling era
never to reach 50 approval even on a
single day during their presidency
and then he had the pandemic come in
which for
uh world leaders that handled it well
was a ticket to an easy re-election
trump mismanaged the pandemic leading to
countless extra unnecessary deaths
and then republicans say oh clearly tru
it's not believable that trump lost
what trump did everything wrong
had a disastrous approval and mismanaged
the pandemic
why would you assume he's obviously
going to win why would you assume joe
biden somehow stole it
of course trump lost and the real shock
is
how didn't trump lose by more trump
still
almost won electorally despite the fact
that he mishandled all of those things
the real tragedy
is that despite everything trump failed
on
75 million people still voted for him so
anybody waiting around for you know the
consequences of what the republican
party and trump became and what they did
and in 2022 it's not going to happen
if they do something disastrous in
august of 2022
then let's talk but as i've said before
republicans don't even know what's going
on
in general voters have short political
memories
and we're seeing that born out already
it's only april of 2021
and more than half of republican voters
don't even understand
and or refuse to believe what it was
that even happened in january
of this year let's take a quick break
let me know your thoughts about
what could impact the 2022 election
i'm on twitter at deepakman we'll take a
quick break and be right back
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at that's joinpacman.com pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
we are a viewer and listener supported
program pre
please grab a membership at
joinpakman.com we do have a coupon code
i think the normal prices for membership
are very reasonable you should see what
some other shows are charging i don't
know how they get away with it
our prices are very reasonable but you
can make them even more affordable with
the coupon code
better21 which you can use at
joinpakman.com
yesterday's bonus show one of the most
popular explosive bonus shows we've ever
done
i told my full story of spring break
including anti uh or masked hesitant
people maybe not antimasters mask
hesitant people i was around
my deep nose swab so many stories
that were uh exciting and titillating
people the first thing you should do
after signing up at jointpacman.com is
listen to the april 5
2021 bonus show okay one of the biggest
justifications
that the open everything crowd has given
for why
everything should always have been open
throughout the pandemic
this includes trump republicans fox news
hosts everybody
the justification was quarantines
guidelines
so-called lockdowns even though the us
didn't have lockdowns
that is causing suicides to explode
suicides are way up except we now know
that
it was completely untrue we now have the
suicide numbers from 2020 we can know
whether that actually happened and the
thought went sure
people might die from covet if things
are open but people will die by suicide
if things are closed
trump endlessly said it suicides are up
suicide suicide here's one example
a prolonged lockdown combined with a
forced economic depression
would inflict an immense and
wide-ranging toll
on public health this includes a sharp
rise in
drug abuse alcohol abuse suicide
heart disease and many other dimensions
of physical and mental well-being
moreover many patients have put needed
medical care on hold
creating entirely new hazards for public
health
our country has suffered the world has
suffered
here's another example of trump making
the same claim
on the ihme model which is now showing
134 000 deaths by august doubling its
previous prediction
are you concerned that that's happening
because some of these states are
relaxing guidelines
no no i'm not because that that assumes
no mitigation
and we're going to have mitigation no
we're letting people out but
the fact that we're letting people go
and go to their jobs they have to do it
you know if they held people any longer
with the shutdowns and
you're going to lose people that way too
and you already have i'm sure
but between drug abuse and i mean they
say
suicide a lot of different things
suicides
way up i could play a dozen two dozen
three dozen
50 100 of these clips of trump and other
republicans talking about
suicide suicide suicides suicides were
down in the united states in 2020. we
now have the numbers
they claimed it without evidence lots of
people fell for it
many people repeated it and it simply
was
not true suicides in the united states
decreased in 2020 according to early
data from the cdc
suicides in 2020 believed to be
the lowest in five years roughly on par
with the lowest in six years according
to the new cdc data
suicides declining 5.6
in 2020 from 2019.
now just because they were wrong as they
almost always are doesn't mean there
aren't
issues of concern here this doesn't mean
there won't be
serious long-term psychological effects
from the pandemic
there will be ptsd agoraphobia
the continued feeling that the world is
dangerous and
you know we have to stay home we have to
stay hidden
it's a long list and there will be
serious consequences for years and yes
part of it will be from the isolation of
the pandemic
part of it will be from people getting
coveted and dying
or having a friend or family member who
got coveted and died
but the notion that the covid prevention
efforts
did more harm than good because suicides
are way up
is simply not true the economy is
recovering very nicely the u.s
government should have done more
during the bottom no doubt about it but
we are seeing that the quote lockdowns
which weren't lockdowns did not do
irreparable harm to the us economy it
did change the economy the economy we
have at the end of this year
is going to be different than the one
that we had in january of 2020 no doubt
about it
the other issue just because death by
suicide was down in 2020
doesn't mean any great victory it was
down 5
nearly 45 000 people still died by
suicide in the united states in 2020
that's horrible that has to be dealt
with that is still a crisis
but the point is suicide didn't explode
because of the guidelines that were
recommended by public health experts
one other note suicide could be down but
depression could be up
and we still need to deal with that that
also has to be looked at so this is not
about
everything they said should have been
ignored it's about
one of their main empirical claims
suicides are way up was
factually wrong one other note the
takeaway for me is not
the isolation and the guidelines and the
distancing aren't so bad
that's not really a interesting takeaway
it's not an actionable takeaway for me
it's more about
we should have a more flexible system as
a matter of
status quo so that people who do better
with work from home
can do it we have the technology for it
there's there's no reason not to
and increasingly if you look at what's
happening happening with office space
demand
it seems as though that is a change that
will become
at least potentially semi-permanent in
the economy
but they were wrong again no explosion
in suicides
suicides down five percent now if you or
someone you know
is not doing well maybe considering
suicide
there are free resources available okay
the national suicide prevention lifeline
you can call it
24 hours a day 800 800-273-8255
okay free 24 hours a day 1-800-273-8255
available to you make it available to
anyone you know
the crisis text line if you don't want
to get on the phone with someone if you
prefer to text
that's fine you can text the word
home to 741 741
that's the 24 7 free
crisis text line there are resources
available
uh make sure you know them make sure
other people you know
are aware of them let's talk a little
bit about
the matt gates scandal the matt gates
scandal broke while we were on vacation
last week republican congressman matt
gates
is under investigation for a whole bunch
of things including possible
child sex trafficking matt gates after
word of this investigation came out
appeared on fox news with tucker carlson
last week
i guess to plead his innocence but he
ended up actually
sort of further incriminating himself
even at one point saying to tucker
tucker don't you remember you went to
dinner with me and a girl i was with and
tucker claimed
i don't know what you're talking about i
mean you couldn't script a more bizarre
story and now we are starting to get
into the phase of
how serious could the crimes matt gates
may be accused of be when it comes to
consequences well dave ehrenberg
who's a state attorney for palm beach
county florida was on msnbc yesterday
explaining that child sex trafficking
one of the
possible crimes gates could be charged
with
it can come with a penalty of life in
prison take a look at this video legal
liability that gates is facing here we
just ran through
quite a few very distasteful things
which of them may end up being crimes
that matt gates could be charged with
well good morning casey the most serious
crime is child sex trafficking which is
punishable by up to
life in prison and there is a 10-year
mandatory minimum
and the more information that comes out
the fewer defenses
matt seems to have left because joel
greenberg the former tax collector of
seminole county
is being charged with child sex
trafficking over the same 17 year old
girl
at issue so the point here is not for me
to tell you ooh
matt gates might end up in prison for
life i'm not telling you
i believe matt gates is going to end up
with life in prison
the point here is that what matt gates
is wrapped up in
could come with a sentence of life in
prison now
matt gates is a privileged member of
congress one of 435
he will get top-notch defense attorneys
there's no way in hell
that matt gates at the tail end of this
ends up with life in prison but the
point is
a normal person might be at risk of life
in prison based on what
matt gates is being investigated for
doing meanwhile
every time matt gates tries to explain
why he's not guilty of anything
he seems to raise more questions and
further incriminate himself
in the tucker carlson interview last
week gates uh said
i've never paid anyone for sex and at
that time that wasn't even part of the
known investigation right the gates
bringing new elements
into presenting derogatory evidence
about himself
uh during interviews further matt gates
said just look at my congressional
travel records they're going to
exonerate me
now when matt gates refers to his
congressional travel records
by definition his congressional travel
records would only refer
to his official travel the disclosures
that gates filed with the house ethics
committee and the federal election
commission regarding his official
trips don't include the stuff that he
was talking about on fox news on fox
news he said
check the records we're going to provide
them they provided them
but it's only his official travel the
the documents that gates put
out don't include who
traveled with gates on a personal basis
on the trips
they don't include what payments did
gates make
for other people to travel with him
personally not as part of his official
congressional travel reservations
and um there's all sorts of trips that
he made to las vegas to yale university
university where anybody could have gone
with him and he might have paid for it
personally
it wouldn't show up in congressional
travel records we would have no idea
about it so again
by raising the issue of travel records
he raises more questions about his
personal travel spending
who he paid for trips for did they cross
state lines how old were
they et cetera et cetera et cetera then
gates claims he's being extorted over
supposedly
bogus fraudulent investigations by the
fbi
that was his claim his dad is being
extorted he's being extorted okay
that puts the spotlight on the
investigations and we realize hold on a
second
these investigations are more serious
and far more broad-ranging than we
initially thought
matt gates might have done even more bad
stuff
than what we initially believed so the
more we learn
every time gates tries to assert his
innocence
the worse it gets and the worse we
suspect his actions of actually being
now
of course he's innocent until proven
guilty there's no question about that
you know every time we talk about uh
stories like this um
i'll get emails from right winger saying
do you not believe in innocent until
proven guilty yeah we do
we're reporting on allegations we report
on allegations when they're against
democrats and people on the left we're
talking about what the investigation is
looking at
we're talking about how every time he
opens his mouth he seems more guilty
of course you are innocent strictly
speaking you're innocent
until proven guilty there's no no doubt
and he deserves a lawyer and a defense
and
all of that stuff then you add to this
that gates was the only vote in the
house of representatives
against an anti-human trafficking bill
in 2017
that takes on a whole new meaning and
dimension based on what he's now accused
of
we've now learned that when matt gates
was in the florida legislature before he
was in the u.s house of representative
gates opposed a bill
meant to stop people from sharing what
we call revenge porn which is
sexually explicit images of
ex-relationships
because gates believed if you have those
images
from when you were in the relationship
those are yours to share
that takes on a whole new meaning in
light of the allegations about gates
sharing pictures with other members of
the house of representatives on the
house floor
this is the guy that wears his
membership
in the supposed party of family values
on his sleeve
and this is the reality that he's
actually living i would love
to see all of this come crashing down
we have a poll that you can vote in
asking what do you think will be the
eventual outcome of the matt gates
scandal it's on our youtube community
tab go to youtube.com the david pakman
show click on community
you can vote in the poll we'll have
results later this week
and of course we will publish those
results to our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
and if you want to see the vacation
picture i posted that
cost me 100 followers
which isn't that much actually but okay
i'm trying to be hyperbolic here
the picture that cost me 100 followers
follow me on instagram at david.pakman
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on
tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow today i'm going to be
speaking with amanda mackey who's an
attorney
and also a republican strategist and i'm
hoping to get
some insight amanda into how you
see the sort of last four years of the
republican party and maybe we can just
work backwards
why do you think trump lost in 2020
um i have said all along and thank you
for having me on your show
um but i have said all along i think
this election in 2020 was a referendum
on the pandemic
um it was really a coronavirus election
and how
some people viewed the handling of
president trump as
not wearing a mask uh not enforcing that
not pushing and promoting those policies
versus joe biden who was you know in his
basement
he was kind of in hiding in seclusion
which maybe a lot of people actually
agreed with
uh that it was you had to be isolated
you should be
and so i think it was really the
dichotomy of how
people viewed the pandemic and how they
viewed the
the response to the coronavirus by the
two different camps
i i basically agree with you i mean i've
said before that if you look at
countries where world leaders handled
the virus well or at least the
perception is that they did and you talk
about new zealand you talk about
australia other places
had trump just said hey you know what
we're printing
maga masks if he had said that on march
20th of 2020
and we're letting the doctors handle
this i think he essentially sails to
re-election and i think the the proof is
and maybe here we'll start to disagree
his major campaign promises he didn't do
any of them the u.s mexico border wall
he added 50 miles he was going to
replace obamacare
he didn't do it he said he would pay off
the debt within four years
he increased it right so so i and it
really didn't matter it re i don't and
we can talk about
why it didn't matter but i think without
it without question
if he just handles the pandemic
moderately well he wins
i think that he viewed his handling of
the pandemic
ultimately as a success because
you do now have uh three or four
depending on the country
uh um vaccines that are on the market
at least in the united states at the end
of his term there were two vaccines on
the market
which i have always said having you know
worked in health care policy as a health
care attorney i mean that's nothing
short of nobel peace prize winning and
you can't say that it's not
now you can't just say that was all
president trump but certainly pushing on
all the levers to get that to market
he said that during the campaign season
and people laughed at him people
mocked him and said there's no way he's
just lying
and in december we were vaccinating
people well but
let's break that down a little bit
though because there's a bunch of pieces
there so
okay um yes trump certainly
funded uh the manufacturer of vaccines
and he pre he did the pre-purchasing of
vaccines on spec
before we even knew whether these
vaccines were going to be approved
that's that's good any any president
would do that i mean
to give him too much credit for that
seems a little strange but when you
think about the the trajectory there
were people saying
december it's never going to happen in
may
goldman sachs put out to the month
an accurate prediction saying based on
the research that's being done around
the world
we expect healthcare workers to start
being vaccinated in in november
and here's where i really am curious
like what exactly you think trump did on
vaccination because
the pfizer vaccine was developed by
turkish immigrants to germany
the moderna vaccine was sequenced before
donald trump
even knew what was going on with the
pandemic
uh so i'm like what exactly did trump do
on the vaccine maybe we can figure it
out well i think just pushing on every
lever of the government to get that
domain operation warp speed
even um you know even uh dr
fauci's boss dr francis collins of the
nih has said that
operation warp speed deserves a lot of
credit
and so i think when you have a ceo which
obviously he was for many years um as
president you know there is just uh
i think he had just a line of sight to
make sure that this happens
and you can say that you know well this
was all in the works well mrnas have
been studied for a decade
so yes i mean technically
pharmaceuticals are always in the works
um but you know pushing that through to
happen in december
no one believed that but what did he do
to push him
for that who did he push though what did
he push
well i can't say exactly what he pushed
it didn't work in the trump
administration but what i can say is
that
when he said every day we're working
through operation warp speed
um to get this done uh you know
everything that comes together
through the government whether it's
lifting uh
regulations or making it easier to get
through
the chambers of government i worked in
congress for
you know a decade and it's not easy to
just get through a very
clunky federal government and
bureaucratic system but amanda what
what regulations really resulted in
vaccines you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to give me something
specific because so far you said you
don't actually know but trump said he
was working hard which often means
watching fox news and tweeting
what what what regulations were lifted
to make this happen more quickly
look i i again i'm not gonna give
specifics because i don't know exactly
what he did and he never said what he
did right so you don't know he did
anything
i'm sorry you can't really say he did
anything then i think that's absolutely
false
now you can look back and say well he
said this or he said that and that
wasn't true
but what the ultimate result was of
these vaccines coming to market i don't
think you can deny that
deny which part that the vaccines were
were made
that the the vaccines were made in
record time
in record time they were made and i i am
sure
that there are regulations that were
lifted there were things within the
government that were done by this
administration to ensure that that
happened
uh with record speed i mean usually it
takes a decade
not for mrna vaccines and therapeutics
to come to market not for mrna vaccines
all right let's move on amanda because
i do have other things i want to talk
about but if at some point there's
something specific you can tell me you
know trump did rather than just he was
claiming that he was doing stuff
we will we will report it about claiming
i mean even when the nih
head like i said who is dr fauci's boss
said operation warp speed deserves
credit he didn't say
pfizer deserves credit he said operation
warp speed operation work speed was a
function of the trump administration
yes now the two vaccines that were first
approved
weren't part of it they did pre-purchase
vaccines
but uh fine okay good so let's talk a
little bit about
policy my interpretation of the
republican party
right now and and basically since the
pandemic
is that it's essentially a party of no
it's
we don't want to do infrastructure we
don't want to do coronavirus guidelines
uh we don't want to do daca we don't
want to do
tax reform we don't want to so so
there's been
really no substantive proposals of
policy
of what they want certainly we don't
want to do any changes to gun
legislation now i've said i don't know
that it's a bad strategy for republicans
and what i mean by that is when you look
at a candidacy like madison cawthorne
for example
his aide or his staffer straight up said
we're not running a policy office
we're running a communications office
it's memes and tweets and talking about
i can put two guns
on my wheelchair and all this sort of
stuff so my question
is do you think that this is a viable
long-term
strategy it might actually be like i
don't know that the republican
party really needs policy given who's
voting for them right now
well the republican party doesn't
control a single lever of the government
in washington right now
but the last two years of the trump
administration they did
uh they had the senate and the white
house
they had the white house and they had
the senate um and the house was
controlled by democrats
right so if you're looking if you're
talking about right now
because you were talking about topics
for right now because certainly trump
tried to do infrastructure and the
democrats said no
um but if you're looking at issues right
now i think i mean look
mitt romney did an interview and you
know mitt romney is
the the king of rhinos i guess you could
say i mean he would probably be the most
moderate the most willing uh to work
with democrats and even he has said that
going at this alone on the coronavirus
bill
uh relief bill was wrong he and i
believe those nine other
republican senators visited with the
president the beginning of february and
said mr president let's pare this bill
down
uh mr president we have other ideas and
president biden did not not only did he
not listen i mean he didn't
pay attention to a single one of their
interests and it sounds like staff was
involved in this
the point is if you want to look back on
president trump he passed
five coronavirus spills with bipartisan
support
and president biden didn't do that with
bipartisan support but amanda that's an
in
that's an indictment of republicans
that's in it that's an indict the fact
you're absolutely right
when it was trump saying we we have to
get money to businesses and the american
people
democrats didn't say we are going to
deny this to trump merely because he's
in the other party because the american
people need it
when democrats said okay well now it's
us we'll do a relief bill that's very
similar to what trump did
republicans said we're not participating
it also
what you've just said is arguably the
biggest indictment of the obstructionist
republicans that i can imagine
what i said no i don't think so using
your own facts because what i said is
that the republicans went to visit with
president biden yeah
and he dismissed everything that they
said he didn't take a single thing into
account he didn't even work with them
he didn't even come to the table and say
let's sit down and talk
what concessions did trump make to
democrats he largely blamed it on staff
as did republicans the staff saying
we're not interested but what
concessions did trump make to democrats
on the coveted bills uh
kennedy center funding uh certainly
other pieces of the
uh of the bill that ultimately the law
that republicans were raped over the
coals for
kennedy center wasn't that like three
million bucks or something
it doesn't matter it's the fact that you
know this is what's interesting to me
yeah president uh trump was impeached
by the house and then three months later
he has nancy pelosi sit down with steven
mnuchin because they obviously
trump and her didn't have a relationship
right and he said sit down
and work something out for the american
people and they did that's leadership
you know you don't pout and say i don't
like her so i'm not going to work with
her
fine did biden said i don't have to work
with you guys because we have 50 50 and
kama will be the
tie-breaking vote so i don't have to
work with you guys so i'm not going to
right trump but but i think isn't the
difference amanda that
trump didn't trump would have done that
if he had had the luxury of having the
house he just didn't that's not that's
not
anything to pro i mean it was just a
reality we can't work in hypotheticals
but i look at someone who was impeached
in the house by nancy pelosi
and three months later she sat down with
his
treasury secretary and hammered out a
bill for the american people but the
reason she had to sit down with her
the reason she had to sit down with
mnuchin was trump
you know didn't want to play in the
sandbox with her anymore because of the
impeachment it's sort of like a
criticism of trump really had his proxy
work with her the ultimate result was a
coveted relief bill wasn't it
yeah just like with biden right the
ultimate result was a coveted relief
a partisan coveted relief bill a
partisan covered relief bill
is it partisan if if 75 of americans
support it that's tens of millions of
republicans what's partisan stupid
relief
of which uh 90 of this bill does not go
to covet relief
we've debunked so we because we i've
debunked that extensively
i don't want to jump into that um so
let's not
jump into that in the few minutes we
have left
what is the policy right now that you
think republicans
should be focusing on what policy now i
know you're saying well they don't
control anything right now okay fine but
when trump controlled everything you
still had democrats proposing things and
saying this is what we would like to see
what are the main policy points you
think would be advantageous to the
republican party right now to be working
on
well the republican party can't work on
anything right now
it would have been nice if the democrats
propose an actual
infrastructure bill because as you know
infrastructure is a key
word for bipartisanship right um but
when you have a bill that's introduced
that even democrats can't agree on
uh where the majority of it is not for
actual roads and bridges
but this isn't my question i'm sorry
i i didn't ask anything i'm just saying
what should be the policy priorities of
republicans
well if if republicans were in control
um i think that uh lowering healthcare
costs
should be an important uh demonstration
of their uh
of their efforts to help americans uh
especially after the last year americans
have consumed a lot of health care so
making sure that
you know whether it's deductibles
out-of-pocket costs are
are not prohibitively expensive for
americans and certainly making sure drug
costs come down
i think you can work in a bipartisan way
on that um look i know
immigration is the third rail of
politics but
we we have got to re-visit our
immigration policies
um when you have you know our
immigration policies are
tailored towards the 1990s mentality of
while you have people coming from
central america and mexico
to the united states to work adults you
don't have
seven-year-olds walking over by
themselves you don't have these coyotes
you know dropping these kids over the
fence that's the new normal
uh in our immigration and if republicans
and democrats don't tackle this
uh that's going to have a huge impact on
the united states and workers in the
united states we still have high
unemployment numbers
and if we're allowing mass migration to
happen and not doing anything to enforce
the borders we're going to have problems
in all 50 states
so so health care and immigration would
be your priorities if republicans could
get things done right now
i think they just need to sit down and
reevaluate the situation i mean what's
happening right now is that you have
coyotes bringing children
across the border why because people
they don't our policies are not to send
children back title 42
don't send the children back they're
allowed to stay here that's why parents
are willing to
separate from a seven-year-old and allow
a stranger to take them across the
border for a better life in america
we have got to prioritize what are the
needs of the united states i'm sure
there are needs that the united states
has
and to say okay we are going to allow
for
uh you know this worker that worker that
we need
and then set immigration policies that
way but if we're nothing or a country of
laws
and you have to re-evaluate the entire
situation you can't look at laws from 30
years ago or 40 years ago and say
well this is our immigration policy
clearly it's not working
yeah i mean it it strikes me when you
look at for for americans
the immigrant i'm not saying immigration
is not an issue it just ranks very low
in in priorities the priorities are
uh you know the state of the economy
jobs
wages health care you did mention and i
think that that certainly would be there
although we might disagree about the
solutions immigration is just quite far
down the list for most americans
well i think that may change when you
have in the month of march alone 171
000 migrants coming to our southern
border yeah
it's not really changing i mean the
polling is pretty steady it just it's
just not
that important to most people i'm not
saying it doesn't matter i just think
it's a very inside politics issue
for most people uh i i don't know that
it's a winning issue for either party to
be quite frank
well it may not be a winning issue but
we have an immigration crisis
unfortunately the president vice
president have not visited the southern
border as bad as it is
they still haven't gone there and i
understand they don't want the media to
be there to see what it is
what would they learn from going though
what would they learn from going that
someone can't tell them
what would they learn from going to the
border that someone can't
tell them it's it's it's the perception
you're the president of the united
states you have a southern border crisis
and you refuse to go
got it kamala harris has been tasked
with this what has she done
in the last two weeks since she has been
tasked with this to show that this is an
important
issue there's a crisis on our border
seven-year-olds are being dropped over
uh you know fences to be able to come
into the united states
no that's fine that's fine but so but
you you're saying it's it's opted the
going to the border is about optics they
could learn everything from
transparency there's been a media
blackout and that's
not transparency this was supposed to be
the most transparent administration
and it hasn't been yeah so i do think
that they need to be more transparent
with the video
from some of the facilities they've
released some but but not others so
that's a beautiful point of agreement
amanda on which
uh on which we can end amanda mackey
attorney and republican strategist
telling us
uh many different things which i am sure
our audience will find very interesting
amanda i really appreciate your time
thank you
did you know the david pakman show is on
all sorts of different platforms find us
on youtube at
youtube.com forward slash the
davidpakmanshow
and on steemit the blockchain based
publishing platform
at steemit.com slash at david pakman
that's s t double e m i t dot com
forward slash at david
pakman all right you really have to see
this fox news is making another attempt
at a so-called comedy show and
and i say another attempt many of you
may not remember this
because back in 2007 fox news tried
doing a comedy show
at the time to rival jon stewart on the
daily show a sort of
like right wing daily show and it was
called the half
hour news hour it lasted only
17 episodes and it was the least funny
thing that you could imagine
fox news is trying it again host greg
gutfeld has gotten
i guess it's a promotion from a
weekend-only show to a weeknight show on
fox news
fox news has been buying billboards
trying to put this show
kind of in competition with stephen
colbert and jimmy fallon and that type
of thing and the first episode premiered
last night
it is completely humiliating
i looked at a bunch of clips which i'm
going to play for you
i don't know how you could make this
show less funny now greg gutfeld
i've interacted with greg greggfeld on
twitter the last time we talked about
greg gutfeld he tweeted about how he
didn't like the clip
i know he may see this listen greg i'm
sorry
the show's not funny i'm not saying it's
you maybe it's the writers
me this show is what the kids would call
giga
cringe let's look at the first clip even
like the live studio audience sounds
not like fake but sort of like they
don't even really understand
comedy i i don't even know how to
explain it but let's look at the opening
moments from greg gutfeld's first
episode
[Applause]
yes
all right here we are again a brand new
show and a brand new greg
i'm as giddy as kamala harris explaining
kids in cages
now genuine question is mispronouncing
kamala
as kamala part of the comedy in some way
is that a joke or does gutfeld
still not know how to say the name of
the vice president
i can't tell what's part of the joke and
that
i'm gonna get back to that because i
think that may be why right wing satire
doesn't work
then gutfeld goes into joe biden
dementia material
if you love the five and felt the need
for more gg that's awesome
if you ended up here because you thought
your tv was the microwave oven
it's good to see you mr president
your pizza will be warm in two minutes
and hunter
he brought the extra cheese
here he is uh yeah here he is rehashing
the old brian williams story from
i don't even know how many years ago at
this point i guess
would you call this a skit i don't even
know what this is
it's painful to watch it's cringe-worthy
to listen to
you all made a great choice for proof
over at msnbc
let's see what brian williams is up to
right now
good evening i'm brian williams and i
am on mars yes i
jumped on a chopper and now i'm on mars
i've been here for a year now
i built a castle here made of mastodon
carcasses
and marshmallows this is where i
invented all the covid vaccines
as well as penicillin the smartphone
and fluffernutter
some things never change meanwhile
what's on cnn
you sir are a racist
racist racist white male
racist
that's from the don lemon hour
i mean just painful painful to watch and
again is it bad writing is it bad
delivery
is it that the material just isn't funny
the left has done satire of of uh some
of this stuff you know the brian
williams thing
and it can be funny i don't know
here's another clip gutfeld taking on
the major league baseball
controversy so screw you mlb your stupid
exhibition game is about as entertaining
as a match of cornhole on espn at 3
00 am in the morning and screw delta and
screw coke
in fact screw all corporations you
stupid execs are cowards and bad golfers
you cheat on your taxes and you cheat on
each other okay so
you get the picture i think there's a
valuable
academic study to be done here is there
something
about the right simply being unable to
do
comedy like what's the problem in this
show
is it bad writing yeah the writing is
bad like even if you give that same
stuff to jon stewart i don't know that
jon stewart can make it funny the
writing is terrible
is it that greg gutfeld can't deliver
the jokes in a funny way
he's not delivering them in a funny way
so maybe part of the problem is
is the host but there's an intangible
there's like a je
that makes so-called right-wing comedy
and satire just completely unfunny
i think two problems are the rights
takes on just about every issue are so
dumb
that when they do jokes and satire you
kind of can't tell like
what's the difference between this and
when trump says
under joe biden there will be no heat
air conditioning and you'll have to
flush your toilet 10 to 15 times
it's equally stupid and it either
all might be a joke or it all might be
serious and because you can't tell
it's part of what makes this very
unfunny and then in addition to that
i don't think right wingers understand
satire so then the live audience is sort
of like they're clapping i guess because
they hear people
laughing it's they don't even really
seem to get it and that's part of what
made the half hour news hour so
disastrous 14 years ago
you might remember the first time i was
on with joe rogan
he explained to me that stephen crowder
does a comedy show stephen crowder's a
right-wing
personality and uh joe rogan said well
stephen crowder does comedy
and i pretended to have no idea like i
was joking i i know that
in crowder's mind ostensibly the crowder
show is a comedic show
but the point was like how can you even
really tell it's not really funny and
the jokes are not
any different than the positions that
many right wingers actually stake out
so this is just really strange stuff
good luck to greg gutfeld i don't know
how long this one is going to last maybe
you know i think half hour newshour was
a weekly show so 17 epis
i think 17 episodes is like 17 weeks
i believe gutfeld's doing this daily so
17 episodes would only be like three and
a half weeks
the only funny thing about the show is
how bad the show is
and i would say check it out for
yourselves you probably don't need to
um but we'll be monitoring it as we do
um
right wing media and we'll see what
comes of it and we'll see if it's fate
is to last more than 17 episodes or not
we might know within the next month so
i've teased this story in the past and
i've said that once enough time has
passed
i will tell the story and this relates
to you know we often talk about
the grift of those who find a particular
right-wing position that may not even
really be their their
opinion or they get pulled in by
audience capture because it's profitable
and they become enlightened to the right
and this applies to cultural critic and
arbiter of big ideas dave rubin
who around 40 years of age i guess
realized that
all of his political positions were
wrong and he became a right winger
uh candace owens is another one who has
staked out a very
profitable position within the american
right and
from much of what we know these were
politics that she sort of uh
fabricated and found once she determined
that they're profitable
i had a lunch meeting years ago and this
person now
has moved on so like they're it's now
been long enough that it wouldn't be
identifiable this went on right around
the time that dave rubin was having his
political awakening i had lunch
with a um i would call them they they
they
weren't they were sort of like a radio
executive but not for a particular
station they was just a very
well-connected person that knew
everybody at
you know clear channel all these
different places and they could they
could get jobs they could say to a
program director
put this person on give them you know
give them an hour a day on on
25 of your stations or whatever had a
lunch with them um
and they said to me listen
um what you're doing is is interesting
it's fine you know my show was much
smaller at the time
but the right is far more well-funded
and what i'm wondering is would you
for x amount of dollars uh become a
conservative and do conservative radio
like how much do you care how much is
this about your politics
versus how much is the of this is about
money and and business
because i think that you're good but
the left just this was when online was
far less dominant and
terrestrial radio was still the thing
the left just doesn't do well on talk
radio the right does
and you know i could get you a job
making x
if you were to do right wing radio and
somehow
shift to the right at the time x number
of dollars
was about three times what i was making
and i said no like me i i couldn't live
with myself i'm not playing a character
here
and we now know of course that there are
many people in media
who do play characters i think that they
tend to be more on the right than on the
left i've never
personally met anyone who does left wing
media who's playing a character
i've met people on the right who
certainly are uh and i said no
and it was i i don't you know say it was
shocking like i had a sense that this
stuff went on
but for me this has never been i'm an
actor
playing the role of a leftist as many of
you know
sometimes i come across on an opinion
that some in my audience don't like it's
not a calculated character for clicks
i'm just giving you my views at the time
as as best as i can kind of present them
now do i regret not going with it and
and tripling my income
no i don't i mean now now what i'm doing
now is far more lucrative
than that would have been remember this
this was some time ago
but this stuff really does exist now it
doesn't tell us anything
definitive about um any particular
person
you know whether it's dave rubin or
candace owens you know there's questions
like is alex jones playing a character
or not
um what about you know who it really
it's not about that
obviously most of us realize that this
kind of grifting
exists but it's not an exaggeration to
say that it can be profitable i mean the
conversation i had was literally
i will call program directors and say
we want to set david up with a slow
transition
out of the left into kind of like they
weren't saying i need to become alex
jones but
become like a center right type of guy
um and i could have a very profitable
show they were even talking about you
know bring your producers we can get
them all hired so
it exists and now the question is
who in media has accepted that type of
offer
who in media is merely playing a
character we know
certainly about about some folks uh and
not about others so
that's the story i'm not going to say
who it was that was offering me
this uh they were a very serious person
the meeting was
you know in a very serious place in in
new york city
um and needless to say it was not for me
it was the right decision i'm i'm
perfectly uh i'm thrilled that i made
the right decision
i'm thrilled morally i'm thrilled
financially
but who has accepted those sort of deals
with the devil i think that it's a very
interesting question
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p here is another caller saying
david
you really don't need to be giving these
disclaimers take a listen to this
hi my name is sam and i was just
watching your show and uh
you talked about the david i mean the
goldman sachs predictions
and you spend a whole 30 seconds deal on
you know they were really good at these
predictions and that's why i'm using
them
you don't have to like goldman sachs and
blah blah blah and i think you could do
it more efficiently by just saying
you know goldman sachs
makes these really good predictions it's
kind of like how
fox news has good polling around the
elections
you don't have to like fox news but
they're just good at that job
and i think everybody would get it
and i think that's where the caller is
wrong not everybody would get it
there is a contingent in my audience
it's the same people
who write to me and say david why did
you support the coup in bolivia
which of course i never did um
and and if i just said very interesting
prediction by goldman sachs and they do
good predictions
and i just go on i will get a hundred
emails uh maybe for
maybe for something like this it's 50
not 100 from people saying
how dare you as a supposed progressive
site goldman sachs as if they're
anything but the epitome
of what is terrible about you
uh so i give the disclaimer now i know
i'm playing to the lowest common
denominator when i do it
but i do it for my own sanity because
otherwise you should see what my inbox
looks like okay i wish i didn't need
the where the caller is wrong is
in saying i don't need the disclaimers i
wish i didn't need them
but i do need them for the same for the
sanity of my inbox
we have a great bonus show for you today
texas rangers home baseball opener 40
000 fans sitting side by side wild wild
times
janet yellen treasury secretary calling
for a minimum global corporate income
tax and i'm going to talk about the lil
nos x controversy
okay on today's bonus show get instant
access by becoming a member
at jointman.com
you